hi mark it's good to see you how are you
good how are you
i'm good i'm good yeah
um i was talking to tom and he basically
said he wouldn't want to face off
against you in a spider-man movie
because you were tough in real life he
sounded scared of you he really did
well
that's good
that's good because i'm the big brother
and you know i never got to be the big
brother i was always the little brother
so i was always kind of picked on and
treated bad by my brothers but i was
always feisty and nipping at their heels
and tom was the same way he wasn't he
wasn't afraid to the point where he
wouldn't try to you know to really step
up and especially when we were
improvising and and really kind of going
at it he was definitely a formidable
opponent he's done a great job and uh
yeah you know he was it was he was good
little brother to have for sure
would you be into playing like a villain
in a spider-man movie have you ever been
approached to play a superhero or a
villain
i i haven't i don't think i and i was
trying to do six billion dollar man for
a while which is based on a television
show but he's definitely kind of falls
in the superhero category but it's just
much more grounded in reality
it's a guy who just kind of has these
special abilities to do and it's really
i wish great wish fulfillment but
i don't know i would it would depend it
would depend i don't want to come out in
the suit and the spandex so
[Laughter]
we'd have to we'd have to negotiate what
the wardrobe would be
and uh and you know i'm always trying to
mix it up and do something different but
i do love and i embrace playing villain
characters i haven't gotten to do that
too many times so yeah i would like to
see that um what did your son say about
this film
my son actually took my son and his
buddy to watch it they loved it and they
saw it really early on there was still a
lot of green screen and stuff so that
normally takes people out of the film
especially if they're not you know from
the filmmaking
community but yeah he loved it he was
excited he thought it was really cool so
i think they're going back to see it
again
yeah searching for a massive fortune in
this film in your personal life what
would you say is your most prized
possession
well that's my family that's my wife my
kids my faith
um
and of course you know i appreciate
really everything that i've had
everything that i've been able to to to
to um acquire or earn i've done that
through hard work
and so things don't normally just fall
in my lap so i really have a tendency to
cherish everything that i have and all
the opportunities that i've had and of
course also paying those things forward
and sharing those with others
oh that is so sweet well you've been i
mean you've been married a really long
time which is a huge deal in hollywood
do you celebrate valentine's day are you
into things like that oh absolutely if i
didn't celebrate valentine's day the
birth of every one of my children
mother's day birthday anniversary
christmas
uh amne every other tuesday that we had
some sort of experience and then i'm in
big trouble so yes absolutely
um before you work with tom years ago
you jokingly i think gave him advice to
move to la with his friends get a
jacuzzi um get a medical marijuana
license
um a lot has changed for tom in the last
few years what kind of advice would you
give to him now
yeah that was probably the entourage guy
in me talking um you know
i gave him lots of advice but
he's got he's got it together you know
here's i would say the worst thing you
could have as a young person he's only
25 and he's already you know uh
recognizable star all over the world he
is you know spider-man which he's done
three movies already now he's got this
other big ten pole film but he's got a
good head on his shoulders and too much
success early on is it's a blessing and
a curse so that being said all the other
stuff that he's doing is usually really
kind of small dramatic parts that really
allow him to show
um and display his talents and gifts as
an actor and get better so i think he's
he's got it down the right way he's
doing he's doing really well i love that
thank you for your time mark thank you
guys it's a pleasure